Speaker 1: Let's go next to Cody from San
Diego. How is San Diego? I was there not long
ago. Love the weather. Great restaurants.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes,
I can. It's pretty grim down here in San Diego,
you know, good, pretty, pretty good weather.
I didn't I kind of had just a scenario I wanted
to comment on. It's kind of like just accepting
just being dumber and accepting that Republicans
very well may win in 2022 and looking forward
to 2024. If likely scenarios keep on happening
and they win, then as well. What's what? What
do you think the climate looks like? I mean,
back in 2016, kind of the narrative around
that I was hearing back then was it whether
Trump or Hillary wins? It's kind of like not
necessarily going to affect the daily lives
of the middle class. And like, we kind of
see some of the repercussions now. Do you
think it's going to be like very like incremental
repercussions type of thing? Or is it going
to be kind of drastic swing changes that we'll
see take place right away if a scenario like
that would happen? Just wanted to.
Speaker 1: I don't know that I understand
you're saying if Republicans take the House
and Senate in the midterms, how radical will
the change be? Is that what you're saying?
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah. In the midterms. And
then also if that compounds into them, taking
the White House in 2024
Speaker 1: 2024 is too far away to say because
that's a few layers away. Here's the things
that will change very quickly if Republicans
take the House and Senate in November. First
of all, no bills are getting passed. So, you
know, Biden did infrastructure. He did a COVID
stimulus bill. You know, there's a number
of different bills that were passed. Nothing
is going to get done. Nothing there will be
nothing done for two years. Except, you know,
if there is the most dire emergency where
the Congress absolutely has to do something,
they're going to do it. But it will basically
be two years of obstructing Joe Biden in an
even more overt way than is being done right
now. Number two Yes, probably there will be
House investigations into Joe Biden and Hunter
Biden, and they may even impeach him, and
they will very quickly make the United States
a joke again the way it was under Donald Trump.
So I think that, you know, when we say, well,
the middle class won't really be directly
affected. Well, I guess that remains to be
seen. But are the reputation of the United
States will very quickly go into the toilet
again as a laughing stock. So it remains to
be seen how quickly they will do these things,
but they will do them. And unfortunately,
I do think they're going to win in the fall.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah, that's the scenario
I see as well, but yeah, just kind of compound
on it on your point, do you think? What do
you think the tangible, I guess, repercussions
of a Joe Biden impeachment would be?
Speaker 1: Well, I don't think it would remove
him. I think it would just be. Remember, the
impeachment is what the House does and then
the Senate would either convict or acquit.
I don't think that that he would get convicted
because he didn't do anything wrong. And so
that's that's a factor. Even with Republicans
having a slight majority in the Senate, I
don't think that Joe Biden gets convicted
on impeachment. I think it will just become
a charade. It will become a distraction and
it will just build the humiliation of the
United States globally.
Speaker 2: Now. Well, I appreciate your comments.
Speaker 1: All right, Cody from San Diego,
thank you. Keep enjoying the the good weather
there. Let's go next to let's go to Ittai
from Copenhagen, Denmark.
Speaker 4: Hi, David, it's good to be on.
Speaker 1: It's a pleasure to have you.
Speaker 4: Yeah. I wanted to ask you, what
are the odds that given the Democratic presidential
candidate in twenty twenty four wins, the
Electoral College and the Republican candidate
refuses to concede that the Republican controlled
Congress will overturn the election and make,
said Republican candidate the next president
of the US.
Speaker 1: So that's a that's a really good
question. So let me let me restate the scenario
so people understand it. Some Democratic candidate
wins the 2024 presidential election. Maybe
it's Biden. Maybe it's someone else. They
win, they get more electoral votes. They are
supposed to be the next president. However,
Republicans, let's imagine control both the
House and the Senate. Could they successfully
prevent the winner from becoming the president
of the United States? My instinct, Itai, is
to say No, it wouldn't happen. They don't
really have the power. They tried to take
that power. Some of them did in 2020. They
don't really have the power, so there's no
way in hell that they prevent the democratic
winner from becoming the president. That's
my instinct. But then I think about, well,
hold on a second. Even in 2020, they weren't
close, but they were close to making it tough.
And so if they were in full control? What
would happen and then I start to get a little
bit scared.
Speaker 4: Let's hope the former case is true.
I also wanted to ask you, what topic would
you like to be taught in public school that
would make the American public more politically
aware and engaged
Speaker 1: a critical thinking and media literacy?
Speaker 4: Oh, that's good, I I would have
picked a course on political ideologies, so
people at least know what the different terms
actually mean.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I see that as only really
being useful if everybody already is educated
in critical thinking and media literacy. I
see those as previous prior steps to jumping
into political ideology, but I don't disagree
with you.
Speaker 4: I see. I also wanted to suggest
that you should cover less the hate mail that
you get beer chats and from voicemails. It's
because we already know that you are getting
it. OK. I mean, I mean, it's it's a given.
I would suggest if unless it's constructive
criticism to just ignore it because it's yeah,
it's not worth your time.
Speaker 1: So listen, I understand that we
do on Fridays. In the last segment, we do
10 minutes of emails and usually there's like
two that are negative. So it's like ten minutes
on one show a week and it's only one or two
of those minutes. So I understand the opinion.
It's a really small part of what we do.
Speaker 4: Oh, I see. Yeah, that was me. How
is. Yeah. Here in Denmark, just so your audience
knows the COVID pandemic is soon over. There
are still some cases, but we don't wear masks
or anything.
Speaker 1: OK. Yeah, there's really no masks
in the in the U.S. either. Hey, real quick,
can you very slowly pronounce Copenhagen the
way you do in Denmark? Because I struggle
to understand how you guys pronounce it? Can
you say it once slowly for me in Danish or
English? In Danish?
Speaker 4: Paraben Howard, it's because the
Earth is a sound that doesn't exist in English.
Speaker 1: OK, and say it one more time slowly
for me.
Speaker 4: Kerr, burn down.
Speaker 1: Wow, so so that the G really disappears.
Speaker 4: Yeah, it does, it does. It's more
of a v sound. Got it, got it.
Speaker 1: All right. Very good. Thank you.
I appreciate the call. Thank you, David, and
have a nice day. You, too. There's it's high
from. Copenhagen is the way I say it.